[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de las esterilizaciones
forzadas a mujeres que ocurrieron en
perú bajo el gobierno del ex presidente
alberto fujimori años después el
gobierno anunció la indemnización a
estas mujeres gracias a una campaña
promovida por la ex congresista indígena
tania pariona junto a la organización
feminista estudio para la defensa de los
derechos de la mujer para ello nos
acompaña maría ysabel cedano garcía
abogada activista y representante de
víctimas de estas esterilizaciones
forzadas gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
muy buen día hablemos entonces de los
orígenes de este llamado programa de
planificación familiar impulsado por el
gobierno de alberto fujimori en ese
entonces cómo surgió y cómo llegó a
descarrilarse de tal manera
buenos días el programa de salud
reproductiva y planificación familiar
fue creado en el año 1996 supuestamente
con la finalidad de poder darle
autonomía a las mujeres como una ruta
para salir de la pobreza sin embargo
entre tan sólo entre el año 1996 y 1997
se esterilizaron a más de 180 mil
mujeres
en su mayoría indígenas campesinas
analfabetas quechuahablantes en
situación de pobreza y pobreza extrema
al estado peruano no le interesó cómo se
hacían y garantizar el consentimiento
informado libre previo y por escrito
tratándose de un método irreversible
ahora qué significan para perú para los
peruanos el reconocimiento por parte del
estado de derecho a la reparación de
estas mujeres víctimas de las
esterilizaciones forzadas
el 8 de febrero el presidente sagasti
promulga la ley que modifica la ley que
creó el plan integral de reparaciones e
modifica los artículos que definen quién
es víctima y beneficiaria de esta
política de reparaciones
incluye a las víctimas de violencia
sexual en todas sus formas conforme a
derechos humanos
la norma tiene que ser definida según el
estatuto de roma de la corte penal
internacional que incluye en la
definición de violencia sexual durante
un conflicto armado interno una guerra
las esterilizaciones forzadas sin
embargo no hemos hasta la fecha
escuchado un anuncio oficial de parte
del gobierno del perú sobre las medidas
sobre los alcances y las medidas de esta
modificación y eso nos tiene sumamente
preocupadas más aún porque
las víctimas están
con una incertidumbre y una angustia
porque porque no se sabe de dónde está
esa esa fuente de información que
piensan ustedes hacer para poder
conocerla para saber exactamente qué es
lo que viene con esta reparación porque
lo que usted está diciendo es que
evidentemente no están satisfechas con
el anuncio que hizo el gobierno peruano
es que no ha habido tal anuncio
y qué piensas hasta la fuente de
información no la conocemos no ha sido
de mus ni la excongresista tania pariona
ni la ex congresista rocío silva
santisteban quien ha salido a decir que
van a haber indemnizaciones o
reparaciones económicas ahora sí cabe
señalar que la ley que ha sido
promulgada tiene entre sus fundamentos y
propósitos el reconocer
de hecho reparaciones de las víctimas de
violencia sexual en todas sus formas que
según el derecho internacional penal y
los derechos internacional el derecho
internacional de los derechos humanos
incluye a las víctimas de esterilización
forzada
y entonces la primera idea clarísima es
que las víctimas tienen derecho a
reparación segundo que tienen derecho a
todas las reparaciones actualmente
vigentes y que el estado peruano en eeuu
tiene que dictar medidas para decir cuál
va a ser el la ruta para ello mari sabes
lamentable situación espero que puedan
solucionarlo todo y conozcan en efecto
qué es lo que le va a hacer el gobierno
peruano para poder reparar las gracias
por su tiempo y gracias a ustedes
continuar con nosotros
[Música]